[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: Flutter is
Google's mobile app
SDK for crafting high-quality,
native interfaces on iOS
and Android in record time.
Flutter works with
existing code,
is used by developers and
organizations around the world,
and is free and open source.
In this course, you'll
learn how to build
a customizable, consistent,
interactive app with Flutter
at a high velocity.
You'll learn about widgets,
app layout, retrieving data
from assets and APIs, and more.
Flutter has strong support
and an active community,
both within Google
and externally.
Start creating apps now
with Building Native Mobile
Apps with Flutter by
Udacity and Google.
[MUSIC PLAYING]